their name literally means dive into the
sea an ethnic minority called the mokan
from a young age they learned to
appreciate the underwater world the
milken are traditionally a nomadic
people who move around the Andaman Sea
of Myanmar's western coast for nearly 50
years Myanmar was cut off from the rest
of the world now it's accessible an
exciting development a team of marine
biologists under the direction of Robert
Howard from flora and fauna
International have explored 28 sites
around the mega we archipelago they
spent 11 days examining coral and fish
for evidence of damage bacteria and
disease so this trip that we put
together this time we've been working
now we were in our third year of
research of the archipelago and we're
just adding to that understanding of the
the reefs and the ecosystems the status
and looking into the future of how we
can manage the archipelago for the
scientists every dive here tells its own
story and it doesn't always make for
good reading the bigger lucrative fish
are largely missing the practice of
fishing with dynamite to boost the catch
has had a devastating impact on the
coral here over the last 15 years
destructive fishing methods have reduced
fish stocks by up to ninety percent
but the next generation will also need
to live from fishing so Robert Howard is
working with the local people and
authorities to set up three protected
areas to be monitored by the Islanders
so the area that's going to be under
protection is about just over 4,000
acres and the coral reefs that we found
with inside lanang with inside the LM ma
are some of the best in the archipelago
and we've actually found some of these
sites of corals around eighty percent
cover this will allow fish stocks in
these areas to recover and help secure
the future of the mokan the scientists
will now analyze the collected data with
a view to setting up more urgently
needed protection zones with myanmar
being closed off for so many years i
guess there was this expectation by a
lot of people that the archipelago was
going to be pristine that there were
going to be fish just everywhere but
however once people got into the water
and started looking at these sites they
found quite the opposite so
unfortunately it's not the pristine
world that a lot of people have this
mind of but still there's plenty of
beautiful sites around that we're trying
to protect now
you